The
Vice
President of the Republic of Ghana,
2,025. President of Ghana, 2,025. Mister vice president,
president to be. You are invited.
Oh, yeah. You're ready also.
Yeah, you're ready. But one second, one minute.
My sister, brother took the ring out of me. Yes.
We members of the Ahmadiyya Muslim community
completely
and completely disown the statement
that the honourable Katie Hammond has made.
He has expressed his own desires,
political desire. Our desire is that leader,
that leader who will lead Ghana once more,
who lead Ghana once more
into his position in the comedy of nations
so that we can command that respect
which Ghana is known for.
That is the leader.
We praying to Allah
that Allah should give us that kind of leader.
The
vice president is here with a huge number of.